John: Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Given that the Quadragocon was a tie, I suppose
that we're going to have to do a Quadragocon
again in 2016.
So I already started training.
But unfortunately during my first training
session I pulled my hamstring.
I wish that were a joke but you can probably
tell from the way that I'm walking that it's
not.
Anyway I'm gonna become someone else today.
Okay I'm here on the Crash Course Government
set.
So Hank as you know Sarah and I have a show
with PBS Digital called the Art Assignment,
where we go around the country and we talk
to contemporary artists and they give you
an art assignment.
One of those assignments, Tameka Norris's
"Become Someone Else", has really stuck with
me so I wanna try it today and I invited my
friend and our office manager Zulaiha-
Zulaiha: Hey!
John: - long time nerdfighter to join and
also become someone else.
Zulaiha: Yep.
John: So the idea is to like change one thing
about your physical appearance and then take
a before selfie and an after selfie of like
who you've become in that process.
Zulaiha: Yep.
Except I'm gonna cheat a little and change
my entire outfit.
John: She's gonna cheat.
Zulaiha: Yep.
John: But I'm gonna play by the rules because
that's who I am as a person.
Okay so first things first let's take our
before selfies.
You're current you right now.
Zulaiha: Yep.
John: And then I'm gonna be current me.
[Singing] Selfie Interlude Music because people
on YouTube really hate silence.
Zulaiha: Ding!
So I'm going to change from my everyday regular
clothing that I wear when I'm in "western
clothing" that is, to traditional clothing
that people like my mom wear everyday and
just don't give two [censored] about what
people think, um because I have a lot of respect
for people like that and who just don't care
and aren't self conscious about that kind
of thing.
John: Do you feel self conscious when you
wear hijab in public?
Zulaiha: No, surprisingly.
John: 'Cause you just- it's just- part of
how you've always dressed
Zulaiha: Yeah, I'm just used to it by now.
John: So I am much more self conscious than
you.
I get recognized a lot when I go out and it
makes me anxious.
It's not bad, like I'm grateful to people
for coming up to me and everything, but it's
mostly what's weirdest is when people just
like take pictures from a distance.
I can feel them looking at me.
And I'm very nostalgic for some reason about
like 2007 to 2009 when everyone I would meet
on the street were like nerdfighters.
And it's terrible to be nostalgic for that
time because of course in the years since
many things that I like have happened.
Like I have had children whom I am quite fond
of and like my book became very successful
and became a movie and stuff but anyway I'd
still kind of like to become 2008 me and you
know how I do that, Zulaiha.
Zulaiha: By putting on hat?
John: That's right.
I put on a hat.
Zulaiha Where are we going out to?
John: I thought we might go to-
Zulaiha: Coffee?
John: Coffee or Chipotle.
So per Tameka's instructions we are now going
somewhere, uh, dressed as our new selves.
How do you feel?
Zulaiha: Kind of the same.
This is what happens when I never go to Starbucks.
John: Uh, we forgot money, so Zulaiha's trying
to download the Starbucks app.
So our trip to Starbucks was completely unsuccessful.
However we did go out in public and talk to
strangers as someone other than ourselves,
right?
Zulaiha: Yeah.
Yeah.
We did do that.
John: What was your experience?
Zulaiha: Um, I didn't feel that much different,
to be honest.
I think that's 'cause I associate wearing
these clothes with my family and I act different
around my family but I don't really act different
around you or at work.
Or maybe I'm just more comfortable wearing
this kind of clothing than I thought I was
and I should just do it everyday.
John: Yeah.
[Singing] Selfie Interlude Music
Zulaiha: How did your hat make you feel?
John: Wearing the hat does make me feel like
someone else and someone I'm more comfortable
being in public, so it's strangely effective.
[Singing] Selfie Interlude Music
Hank, what I love about the Art Assignment
is that it makes me do and think about things
I wouldn't usually do or think about.
In this case it made me think about what's
changed and what hasn't in the last few years.
Hank I think some kind of loss is inherent
to change but doing Tameka's assignment reminded
me that I am always becoming someone else.
So thank you to Tameka Norris.
Check out the Art Assignment.
There are lots of great assignments and lots
of great videos about contemporary art.
Hank I wonder if you had to become someone
else who you'd become?
I'll see you on Friday.
Oh wait!
P.S.
The wonderful people at Penguin UK are doing
an awesome project to raise money for the
Teenage Cancer Trust.
It's got a Fault in Our Stars theme, so if
you live in the UK or Ireland please check
out nightofinfinities.co.uk Thanks bye!